I really don't have enough gas to waste
around for this but
I like that it reminds you of what
happened in the last episode
which is that the monster broke into the
safe room also high on back yeah right
use your wits and your brains but if I
don't have either of those okay so here
we all right the eye thing you remember
the eye thing of course you remember the
I think Lexi and remind him of the eye
things
hello are mad class assist has struck
again Noir has filed the report claiming
that the Romans used these tunnels to
hold sadistic
great festivals of cruel combat torture
and worse
further he says these were all held in
an arena over a great pit any who fell
into it fell into screaming Darkness his
words what a poet I've been in the
tunnels there tunnels full stop
recommend surveillance on Neuer yeah
what was Neuer doing again
uh uh Neuer was talking about this
language Latin yeah wild stories blood
orgies sadistic Spirits right so I'm
going down into the thing and I'm going
to do something
uh so I'm gonna go do that
um I just got through the water area and
I think I'm gonna try to get the plunger
for the explodies
because that should allow me to be able
to get out of here
theoretically but somehow I highly doubt
this seems like a carefully orchestrated
path back as if I was going to be
running away from something horrible
but surely I wouldn't be running away
from anything horrible
here at least this is here so maybe I
could have a path
oh never mind there was a way over here
I was a big dumb idiot oh that is a
familiar blue glow
oh that is an achingly familiar blue
glow
that reminds me of maybe rebirth in a
way am I crazy about that
what does that feel
just a little bit familiar
oh
interesting was that a note for me was
that a was that a map
well I don't care the map on me it's in
my safe room which doesn't feel so safe
anymore
okay
well I'm guessing if they're tunnels and
there's definitely a way that that thing
was able to get around here oh that
looks familiar
oh
is vibrating oh it is vibrating
is this related to rebirth I mean I
think they all take place in the same
universe but that looks achingly
familiar
fascinating
yeah did the um other soldiers not say
anything about the weird humming
floating vibrating crystals
because to me those are really weird
to me those are a little strict
for the world
secretary by 12.
uh-huh tell me more I want to know more
yeah
uh-huh okay
[Music]
is that a French accent
uh-huh
[Music]
I see okay
oh
[Music]
hi
what am I what is um
what
am I am I seeing things or are there
multiple people
walking
wait a minute
what do you mean
ghosts do you have a ghost in
you got ghosts now we got ghosts ghost's
thing
[Music]
uh-huh
yeah uh-huh hold on let me think about
that that's really interesting
[Music]
a generator isn't it running
the sky
well I don't like the fact that I can
see ghosts
hey whoa whoa
whoa
what are you doing
[Music]
oh God
are you coming for me are you gonna
shoot me
are you gonna shoot me
[Music]
Granada
well that would be very useful
hold on
[Music]
am I supposed to kill him can I kill him
is he coming
next
around the bend
I don't know
I don't know man
[Music]
I can't see nothing more likely
another wizard
[Music]
that Tom's men in tegration aggressor
man into griesel
right
or is that locked
foreign
I have a plan keep singing oh it's a
good one I think that's why they put the
grenade there but I have one of these so
I'm going to use it
uh fire in the hole
good that's what I was going for oh God
oh God really oh
oh frick
Ulfric
we were a worldly worldly world
yeah we were the world
oh
freak oh freak
oh freak
get the bullet
freak
oh
I don't know if that was what I was
supposed to do but I felt like my life
was in danger I felt like that was
perfectly Justified
drop this
because oh wow it's a shotgun
that's awfully handy okay
well that's good to have I suppose
um
so you tell me this guy had nothing
no bullets in this but that's okay all
right so I'm I know I'm taking this
really slow like agonizingly slow but uh
I don't have any other thing to do
oh so I don't know what was going on
with that dude but he was not well
um
and that's okay
we all go through some stuff uh but I'm
still not about someone trying to blast
a hole in my butt so I'm not gonna let
that occur
uh at random that's for sure
so
yeah
why am I
this
why am I this ooh I suppose what I could
do there was that other door over there
that was still blocked up so what I can
do instead of wasting this I can grab a
bottle
fill it with gas
and then this will also have the added
benefit of clearing up my inventory a
little bit picking up this and then I
should be able to grab that other
canister of gas no problem at the very
least I I think this should burn this
door down right unless I'm
really really mistaken which I might be
and if this doesn't work then I should
just be able to you know do something
else
okay let's see I don't know if that'll
work that way but
whatever
yeah maybe not maybe maybe that was
maybe that was a dumb idea maybe maybe
that was wrong maybe maybe that was
maybe that was really dumb uh did you
have a key on you oh man okay yeah that
was that was pretty dumb of course that
wouldn't work why would that work well I
have a grenade so that's gonna work for
sure
so why not
[Applause]
oh
oh okay all right I was about to say
that didn't work it would have been
sorely disappointing
and also this is where I'm gonna find
out that there was another way in here
that was perfectly accessible and I
didn't need to blow that
oh
more items nice
that's real nice
oh that path
is that a path that I want to take or is
that a path that a monster should be
able to go by because um half a donut
half a dozen is there anything else in
this room that I needed
ah
ah well I guess I couldn't go in there
that was still blocked up
there's got to be some goodies that I
haven't seen a lot of bottles French
soldiers they love their wine that's for
sure but nothing that's going to help me
just yet because I've already done my
wello so let's find out what the weird
glowy uh Alcove of nightmares is that's
fun
oh boy
oh
so that uh so all this makes sense
because I gave was it am I ornery I I
can never remember who I am
no I'm Henry I gave
Lambert
I gave Lambert this glowy water which
again I don't remember it being glowy
the last time I was here but at the same
time
feel like uh
maybe it was a bad idea oh
man I I really shouldn't have brought
these I thought these would have been
more useful than they were I thought it
was going to be like everywhere you go
there's going to be a secret that you
can Clip open or wrench open but
apparently not apparently that's not
what it is hey now don't don't do that
Lambert ah good that's good and then I
should probably get this
uh
who needs fuel not me definitely not me
didn't I like sling a rope down or
something to get
glambered out of here didn't I do that
wasn't that a thing I did
let me take a dip oh
maybe I could take a swig
join Lambert
Lambert ecstasy that is Monster dumb
no all right just me then okay so I've
got what I need to be able to blow the
front entrance but also I feel like that
was a pretty uh
I'm pretty apt now the question is
can be thrown
interesting very interesting
I hate that
very interesting can be thrown
fascinating
wow
so I'm sure what that refers to is this
is in um Lambert's Journal there was
something about a toy that he got for
his
kid uh something like that
and I'm sure that this is it and so this
is going to have some sentimental value
for the monster but what is it gonna do
that's
that's what I don't know okay well that
was um not without incident but that was
um
what I needed I have no idea whoa I
didn't know I was pulling that out
all right uh well I mean I have a bullet
I thought I was
thought I would you know I see I see
okay well I'll just hold on to the
bullet for later something is very
reassuring about this
but also something's very reassuring
about this I mean they wouldn't have
this item in like an Alcove to be able
to go around and around to be able to
see that unless there was a very
specific reason
to grab it right it's it's a rabbit
and it can be thrown
uh-huh
okay it was a little bit drippier than I
would have liked seemed excessively
drippy I have no idea what the generator
status is it's probably definitely off
but I don't see any reason to hesitate
getting back
I have some gas at least and I have the
Detonator plunger so
I'm getting close right
don't
don't do anything
water monster related
that's all I ask
I just asked no water monster
[Music]
oh
please
that's a weird red glow
lights are definitely off
everything's fine
okay okay
okay
so far so good
um
[Music]
lights seem very extremely
it'd be worth it going in this door for
that I have a grenade so I mean no time
like the present right you know what
let's do it
final
plus I can try throwing this to the
thing
oh
what was that
did it
must have hit a mine well that was
awfully convenient thank you for that I
think it ran away afraid
oh
what is that oh gas grenade no need for
that
just here for the map I guess
aha
yeah
uh
nothing important
photo here
aha oh that's handy
if I had known that literally the entire
game ago that would have been incredibly
helpful
as it stands no thank you
all right let's get back
I've got a rabbit
anybody want a rabbit
okay
oh is this it or what
I know this doesn't actually help
because you know you know
so I can't help but think that there's
something about so the monster
its home was the chapel right I have
this rabbit and it's definitely
sentimental to
limo and I got another code so there's
definitely something else like it cannot
be just I blow it up and I'm done right
it can't be that easy or maybe it is
that easy I don't know whatever it is I
don't like it and honestly I'm I'm not
about it so I'm just gonna what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna put I don't have
anything
um
oh man
I guess I could put this stuff in the
thing but I don't know it's it's extra
ominous here and I don't like it oh I
swear if you're down there
oh
there's a lot of noises down here
did not appreciate that
okay I'm gonna make this quick I'm just
gonna go see the chapel just because I'm
like
it probably means something I don't know
what but it probably means something so
I'm just gonna go to the chapel I'm
gonna take this with me I'm gonna take
the shotgun cause please yes put this
here
we go all right I'm going for it
let's see what happens
and I'll also open up the case at the
same time so Chapel is down the other
way I believe
-3883
Lambert here we go
shotgun show hell yeah and a note 12
July 1916.
up again
in the chapel trying to pray but my mind
is too alive with thoughts of the crater
the rabbit
without water
and yet I don't feel tired
instead I feel this
sense that there are things I must do
purpose a bloody purpose higher than any
of man's Petty Wars
13th July 1916 morning
everyone's talking about hearing
scratching at the walls
Conley even claims to have heard howls
echoing through the barracks
I shall strange myself
can barely find the words to write
odd
gnarled bulbas
like they don't belong to me
I hesitate to write this but
echoing in my head
thought I must not act on are bloody
thoughts of seductive
which calls
calls it calls
picked calls
15th July 1916. Madness in the Parks
this morning
's dead they say murder but will not
show us the body
a dream rises in my mind
countless crew eyes upon me
must check on Ari
wish he would wake
could use a friend
prayers
remain unanswered
18 July 1916.
blood on my hands
from brother man
's blood on my hands
their pains
I want more of it
I can hear it tumbling now
to lean closer
closer
I can get what I want from it
okay well uh that's nice how did you
manage to stuff that in your locker uh
um you know
before you know you know so there's
actually quite a few people a gas mask
wait a minute grenades wait a minute you
telling me are there things that I've
missed or is this just
you being sassy all right I'm gonna go
to the chapel I'm testing this Theory
right now is this a theory
but it's a game theory and I gotta see
it through to the end
that's what I'm here for I know it's
down here and I've opened up the paths
that can go there I haven't really oh
maybe maybe I had to double back and do
the things with the um
uh there was like I died a few times in
this area and it it caused some issues
and then I don't think I went back and I
don't think I got some notes maybe even
some uh messages
from people
why is it why is it oh it's saving all
right
so it is oh hello I didn't even get that
well useless
very useless there is that oh oh
well
sure would be a shame if this made noise
I really don't have enough gas to waste
around for this but
all right
why did that happen I feel like that
shouldn't have happened I feel like that
shouldn't have happened damn it I gotta
go get oh
that place that area is cursed for me I
don't know what it is but down in that
area I can't do nothing there ain't
nothing I can do then nothing
oh yeah
oh strange bulbous hands the bloody
calls seductive blood okay whatever
load her up okay I got three shots of
this bad boy wait there was there were
there were mises mises that needed to be
taken care of and I can do that because
I have a torch and a church is a very
effective tool of dealing with mises
because they run away but I gotta be
careful or else they're gonna nibble on
me
I just got to make sure they stay away
I guess it was pretty close to that but
whatever you know what I'm not even
gonna bother with it
I know there's probably some
completionist stuff that I can get if I
do that but I I just God I just really
wanna figure out if I'm right about this
freaking doll oh yeah these if
I run by I should be fine before
not today but
all right
fuel storage huh I still feel like this
is a big ass bomb but I do have the wire
cutters and that might mean that I can
do something about that
I don't know why I just have the
Instinct that coming here should be able
to do something about this
I wonder if I put this here
you go Bud
oh
unless
that's probably not right
oh boy wow
um
this place is ooh so delightful
yeah yeah maybe this was a mistake maybe
I should just throw it at him okay what
if I just find one of the holes that
he's gonna stick his arm out of and then
I throw it where his arm is and he'll
grab it
that makes sense right in the meantime
maybe I can grab some more fuel if I
know how to do this right which I'm not
100 sure that I do
but I do have this
so let's try
uh yeah come on yeah
[Music]
come on how is this not oh there we go
oh I'll take that thank you very
much
whoo that would have been explosive
um
use an empty bottle to fill the bottle
with fuel oh
that's pretty cool drop that for now
so I have unlimited fuel is that what
you're saying
unlimited fuel
I guess I could use that to
could I use that to fill the I suppose I
could
like theoretically I could use that to
fill up the um uh the uzi was it if I if
I needed to that's the thing I don't
know if I need to
but it's potentially unlimited because
The Wine Cellar is right around the
corner from here and and I could just
make a supply running
indefinitely I would have fuel for
indefinite
indefinitely but why would I need to
that's the question okay so if I wasn't
right about that
then let me try to find some place where
he's
oh boy
power about to run out is that what it
is
oh my God I bet it is oh my God oh
I feel like I know this isn't Five
Nights at Freddy's but it feels like it
oh
foreign
oh God here we go
did you take it
I took it I think
wait did you but I thought
hey but I thought
but you took it right
oh God
uh okay I don't know if I did that right
probably not
um
uh
I'm gonna see about filling this if this
works God I hope it works
whoa
whoa filled it up good oh my God talk
about you get a bonus with the bottles
hey wait what about wait the bottles hey
wait I thought we recycled not poured in
Gold Bush another I thought it was going
to be a bit more efficient than that uh
well apparently not good to know uh I'm
gonna go ahead and put the plunger in uh
maybe that'll
I feel like I'm missing something I'm
I'm missing something but I got this
plunger and I'm like
hmm what else do I do
you know what I mean
okay that he probably won't plunge it
immediately right no he won't okay so
it's there
ready it's primed but I'm missing
something that's what I know is happy
I'm missing something unless it is just
get out of here
why why was the bunny so important
maybe it wasn't important maybe you
didn't grab it
oh
oh he didn't grab it
uh I'll take that
I'm just gonna go get more fuel because
that's it's very nice an entire a one
bottle is an entire thing of fuel that's
delightful so we didn't take what the
rabbit I feel like it's important
I just feel like it's kind of important
It's gotta be right it just feels
important I don't know why it feels
important maybe it's got to be out and
chasing me and I gotta give it to him
thank you
all right
that's funny
I don't know if I should tempt fade but
after I make this run I'm gonna attempt
fate I'm gonna try to like dance around
while um
I got my pants down or something
drink up buddy
all right let's go tempt fate hey buddy
there is that break room that I haven't
gotten into I've been in the soldiers
quarters been in all this stuff I've
been all over there I've been in the
prison that guy's still alive uh Mission
storage done all that stuff doctor's
office been there officers met Hall the
kitchen yeah that's where that guy died
let me actually look
while I'm running around trying to throw
its attention so the names of the people
are
Travers Laval who have a gas mask why
and then Bowser Travers love all and oh
oh freak
oh my God
oh God here we go I'm being stupid hey
hey
why
whoa oh all right get ready here we
go take one of these yeah yeah
it's a rabbit
you like the rabbit
you like the rabbit don't you
you like that rabbit
you like the rabbit
yeah
you like the rabbit don't you oh
he took it
he took the rabbit oh good oh yeah that
was it yeah
I guess that's it I had to take my gun I
took off my I I don't feel like I I
don't know
I win
oh
oh okay I was about to say if that
knocked me unconscious I was gonna
I was gonna be very confused
progress saved
oh
wait a minute wait you wait you
you uh uh you you are uh uh
uh uh wait a minute you uh wait
but I wear I wear I won I
but
I won I win I I did it
huh
what's going on
oh
huh
all right
oh
monster wait I gave you a toy don't do
it wait hold up wait hold on hold up
don't do it
don't do it I should have gotten a whole
bunch of fuel oh
don't do it I gotta whoa I got this
all right you wanna play
it wasn't I aiming
oh I gave you something boom I'll give
you something else I'll try you want
some money
did that hurt
that's what I thought yeah you get out
of here
yeah you get out of here
I don't know anymore oh you're cut oh
you're not getting it out of here oh I
thought you were gonna get uh oh okay uh
oh ah
oh
I thought you were gonna get out of here
um oh boy
I can't see
um what's that what's a shotgun
yeah
I like that
all right all right lamby
all right lamby Bambi
all right lamboner you don't mess with
me
hey is this your way it's your way buddy
trying to I'm trying to understand what
the what the oh interesting huh oh try
to get me now
fool
can you jump that
oh oh frick oh oh oh oh
did you jump why does it sound like
you're jumping oh you're just mad
okay
um well oh uh what oh oh uh oh
God I don't want to waste too much ammo
go the other way I'm going this way now
let's try oh shh wait that's that's not
what I wanted to do
oh wait where where are you going
which way you going
oh
I might be able to trap it over there
phew why do I need you
I'll trap it I'm gonna trap it I'll trap
it I'm gonna trap it I'm gonna trap it
I'm gonna trap it you're gonna be
trapped buddy get trapped nerd I guess
you could go the long way around
thank you
or he's already over here okay I don't
know how that happened I'm trapped
I'm a nerd okay all right
oh you're trapped nerd yeah
yeah what do you think of that
what do you think of that loser
ah there's a lot of bridges
I don't know if I'm trying to get it
trapped over on this side over here
I think that's probably worth trying to
do I don't know where he's can't see
anything where am I where is he where is
he where am I oh I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go I'm going I'm gone
oh you trap nerd
I guess he could still come up the
Center Way couldn't he
but not if I do this get it get it now
now now
get a gun
all right well I oh well I did I did
open up that that bridge did blow
which is great for me
not the best for everything else but I
think that is the right strategy I'm
just trying to get it over there I am
dying oh I need another thingamabob
I really should have loaded up on fuel
or something I didn't know that this was
going to be like a
like a final confrontation deal all
right if I can just loop-de-loop around
I might be okay
but he needs to be like all the way over
here I don't think he can go over here
yeah you mad
you mad
you gonna be mad you about to be mad go
go go go go go go go yep that's it
you're done so how are you gonna get
over here now
you ain't
you ain't the answer is you're not
answer is you don't
oh wait a minute
[Music]
ah it might have been futile
a good gas great I'm bleeding out
I'm horrifically injured
horribly wounded
nope not even area cloth okay so I think
what I need to do is I need to create
this oh you're over here are you over
here you better not be over here all
right I created some time and some space
that better last that's all I gotta say
about that it better last
I'm over here in Alexander's private
collection
you better not kill me immediately
okay okay
oh come on all right
all right
okay I did that I did that thing
the thing I did it
can I please get like uh one cloth
one scrap
pretty please
oh freedom
freedom freedom
oh no no not like this no no I'm so
clumsy oh no
foreign
all right
that's fine that's that's very fine
oh this is equally as terrible
oh
oh not the Germans oh
laughs
that was great interesting boss battle I
also realized I could have just run for
it
um and that would have been probably
totally fine but I feel good for having
done that I think that was tremendous I
am very very happy with my experience
but also I missed things I know I did I
I know there's like a true ending
what is this
longest time between saves not very long
yeah I saved a lot killed a lot of rats
yeah
yeah no flares thrown who would do that
corpse is burnt is that what I was
supposed to do I'm spotted by stalker
stalker bullet hit count rat scared by
torch nice good stats good stats
that was great on finishing your first
playthrough of Amnesia the bunker
remember no plethora of the bunker is
the same as any other items traps codes
and more are all random
I love that there's custom stories I
love that I can't wait for custom
stories but also but I gotta look at the
achievements I gotta do that okay here
we go
quit the game right as things get
interesting right reacquired the rabbit
ah interesting sent the Beast
achieved by defeating the beast in the
final area what I didn't defeat it I
thought I defeated it I defeated it
I definitely defeated it got the cutter
and locked the cell again without the
German prisoner dying I did do that
blessed
blew up lots of rats with a single
grenade I think I did that but I don't
know shot at the Visions in the tunnels
yeah I wanted to
never dropped nor stored an item damn
complete the game faster than all
developers at fictional damn completed
the game without saving damn well
there's no secret true ending or is
there but something about defeating the
the Beast I have no idea I didn't do
that but I coulda if I'd have even known
that that was what was about to happen
but I should have known that but I
didn't but whatever either way thank you
everybody so much for watching sorry for
the delay on this obviously life gets in
the way but I'm glad that I finished it
and I can't wait to see what kind of
custom stories people cook up should be
fun thank you and as always I will see
you
in the next video
next video bye-bye
[Music]